passe la parole à présent madame
marie-thérèse bruguière pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire
merci merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre vous avez pratiquement
répondu à la question que j'allais poser
mais il ya quand même encore quelque
chose que je voudrais éclairé
aujourd'hui en france la france compte
1000 gynécologue et selon les
projections selon les projections il ne
serait que 600 en 2015 et 181 2020 pour
le même nombre de patientes donc les
délais pour obtenir un rendez-vous sont
de plus en plus longues il faut même
quelquefois attendre jusqu'à six mois
selon les territoires semin que
d'effectifs fortement préjudiciable pour
le suivi de la santé des femmes d'après
les données évidemment de l'institut
national d'études démographiques
12,2 pour cent des 20 24 ans ont déclaré
en 2010 ne pas avoir de suivi habituel
contre 6,9 en 2000 pourtant cette
spécialité médicale est la seule qui
garantissent aux femmes un suivi
personnalisé notamment en matière de
prévention et de dépistage de certaines
maladies ce qui fonctionne très bien
dans notre pays en effet le nombre des
cancers du col de l'utérus a été divisée
par quatre en vingt ans on est le pays
où il ya même le moins d'hystérectomie
pour le néo dussaigne une des meilleure
survie en europe
84% de survie à cinq ans alors pour
pallier ce manque d'effectif tout à
l'heure vous en parliez madame la
ministre j'ai bien entendu que pour 2013
on aurait trois de plus que pour
d'effectifs trois de plus que pour 2010
2015 nous passerions à 35 ce qui
effectivement augmente d'un petit peu
mais c'est peut-être pas encore
insuffisant et j'appelle votre attention
qu il ya de plus en plus de jeunes
femmes et de jeunes filles de 14 ans qui
préfère consulter et de da de femmes
d'âge mûr qui préfèrent consulter un
gynécologue unicode médical plutôt que
l'obs et riz sien est difficile de se
retrouver un certain âge dans des salles
de cause d'attentes avec des gynécos
avec des femmes enceinte jusqu'aux dame
par ailleurs la loi du 21 juillet 2009
dit elle hpt hspt pardon prévoit de
recourir à des prévisions quinquennales
vous nous avez répondu je vous je vous
en remercie madame la ministre des
années d'action obstiné ont abouti à
l'as à la création le 1er février 2013
d'un diplôme spécifique de gynéco
médicale ces années de combat ont
exprimé de façon éclatante l'attachement
des femmes à cette spécialité sur mesure
pour elle et je dis bien pour elle
aujourd'hui cet attachement demeurent
les femmes d'un âge mûr et je viens de
le dire préfère consulter un médecin je
me répète chacun son champ de compétence
de la même manière que les accouchements
il faut des gynéco obstétricien et des
sages-femmes des puéricultrices pour les
enfants merci madame la ministre d'avoir
écouté je crois que la réponse a déjà
été donnée c'est peut-être pas la peine
que vous vous rendiez merci merci chers
collègues je passe tout de même la
parole à madame la ministre si elle
souhaite réagir avant l'arrivée
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice moi je partage comme j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire le constat que
vous posez comment en est on arrivé là
parce que un peu d'histoire est utile
c'est madame michèle barzach ministre de
la santé de monsieur du gouvernement
chirac qui en
1986 a supprimé la spécialité de
gynécologie médicale alors qu'elle même
était gynécologue roselyne bachelot qui
a été ministre de la santé du
gouvernement fillon a consacré la fin la
gynécologie médicale en réduisant le
nombre de places à l'examen classant
national et en considérant que cette
spécialité n'avait pas de raison d'être
ce qu'elles donnaient comme
argumentation était que la gynécologie
médicale était de plus en plus
spécialisés devaient se développer dans
le cadre de projets cliniques à
l'hôpital donc renvoyaient à des
problématiques très spécifique mais
qu'en ville les fans pouvaient se
tourner vers d'autres types de
professionnels je crois que cette
approche
exclusivement hospitalière de la
gynécologie médicale a contribué à peser
sur la démographie des gynécologues
médicaux et a constitué le problème
auquel nous sommes aujourd'hui
collectivement confrontés et donc
veut indiquer que comme je les ai dit ma
volonté de faire en sorte que les femmes
puissent trouver en ville un gynécologue
médicale parce que c'est bien cela
l'enjeu dans l'ensemble de nos
territoires sous des formes qu'il faut
évidemment organisé et aménagé et avec
les mesures que j'ai commencé à prendre
et bien à la fin de 2016 et dans la
perspective de l'examen classant de 2017
nous devrions considérer que nous aurons
formé 50 % de gynécologues médicaux en
plus que si nous étions restés au nombre
de gynécologues médicaux formé en 2011
il me semble que c'est une étape
volontariste importante qui aura été
franchi
merci chers collègues voulaient
prolonger le
chevreau mars